-That's what I'm talking about.
Welcome to the show.
Welcome back. Kenan, Kel, we've
got a lot to talk about here.
Okay. We always have fun
together when we get together.
It's been 25 years, though,
since the movie "Good Burger,"
came out.
-Whoa.
-This is true.
-Isn't that wild?
-For real.
-That's very wild.
-It's crazy.
-25 years.
-Clap it up for time.
-[ Laughs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I have a photo here.
Look at these guys.
-Let me see.
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Let's do it.
-You're making the face.
He's got the face. You guys,
he's still got the face.
Come on, he's got the face!
Yeah!
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
And I think it was probably,
like --
I think it was seven years ago,
you came on my show, and we did
a bit, a reunion, like a little
fun thing of "Good Burger."
And everyone went nuts.
The Internet went crazy.
I think it's up to, like,
30 million views on YouTube.
-Yes!
-That sounds like a lot.
-That sounds right.
That sounds like a lot.
You guys have a big announcement
to make.
You came exclusively to give it
to us, tonight,
on "The Tonight Show."
-That's right.
We had to do it here.
Let's do it.
-Kenan, can you tell us
what's going on?
-Um, ladies and gentlemen,
Kel has something
he'd like to tell you.
-Wow.
All right, here we go.
Kel, whenever you're ready.
-Ladies and gentlemen...
-Oh, wow.
-"Welcome to Good Burger,
home of the Good Burger..."
part two!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Yes, yes, yes, yes!
Yo!
-What!
Wow.
-Dude!
-What!
-Come on!
-Come on, baby!
-What?! "Good Burger 2."
-Two!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes!
"Good Burger 2."
"Good Burger 2!"
Come on, now.
-Oh, man.
-How exciting is this?
-It's a blessing, man.
It's unbelievable.
We're going to shoot it this
summer, and it'll be out soon.
-When -- How did you hear?
How did this --
This must have been in the works
for a while.
Did it come from this thing?
Did it come from "SNL"?
-I mean, it's been years.
Like, pretty much
since the first one --
-Since the first one,
we wanted to do two.
-Yeah.
-The crowd, we want it.
The people have spoken.
We want to see this.
-That's right.
-They have spoken.
-It's happening.
It's happening.
-Yes.
-That's such a big deal.
I'm so excited.
So, when you started
on "All That," okay?
You're just straight out
of high school
or you were in high school?
-A freshman. 14 years old.
-Barely.
-Sophomore, yeah.
-15.
-And did you know each other
before you got the show?
-We didn't,
and it was funny how we all met.
I don't know if they planned
this, but they had all the kids
come one by one off the elevator
in the lobby.
And I remember I was down there
already, and the elevator opened
up, and this kid came out
with Mighty Ducks gear on.
[ Light laughter ]
-Wow --
-And he had the roller blades
and everything.
He did the whole like, err!
And I'm like, "I've got
to hang out with that kid."
-Wow!
You were wearing the swag?
-I was a very proud Mighty Duck,
yes.
-Yeah, you were a very,
very proud Mighty Duck.
But what made you guys click?
'Cause sometimes, you don't know
who you're going to click with.
'Cause it's almost like making
a super group, like the Avengers
of young comedians.
-Bro, yeah, I feel like with me
and Kenan, it was just like,
I would say a joke,
and then he would finish it,
and it just felt like we gelled
really good.
And then it was in "Mavis and
Clavis" where we figured it out.
-"Mavis and Clavis," dude.
-Yeah, "Mavis and Clavis,"
yeah, yeah, yeah.
We were playing the two old men.
-For reference, "Mavis and
Clavis" were two old Black men.
[ Laughter ]
And --
-And you were 14 years old?
-Yeah, 14 years old, kind of,
like, doing the references of,
like, our dads, uncles,
grandparents.
It was like, "Oh, this guy
is very similar to myself.
I love this dude."
-Yeah, yeah.
-And did you know
that "Good Burger" clicked
when you just did that sketch?
And you were like, "Oh."
-It was a fire sketch
from the beginning.
It was one of the strongest from
like -- it was in the pilot,
right?
-Yeah, "Good Burger?"
Oh, yeah.
-Do people still quote you on
"Good Burger" all the time?
-Oh, dude, I get it every day.
Yeah, doesn't matter.
Any restaurant that I go to,
could be five star
or it could be drive through.
they always go,
"Welcome to Good Burger,
home of the Good Burger."
And I love it.
I get free burgers.
-Yeah, why not.
That's a good gig.
-That's a good gig.
-Is that the only line?
What's the other line?
-Oh, the other one.
Oh, "Who loves orange soda?"
-Yeah.
-"Kel loves orange soda."
-You got that.
-Yep.
"I do, I do!"
And then --
-Very close to home for people
right now.
-Yeah, man.
-Right in the childhood.
-Right in the heart.
-I love it, man.
-Can you tell us what's going to
go down in "Good Burger 2?"
-Ooh
-Hijinks.
I'd like to say
a lot of hijinks.
-Got to love that.
-Yeah, got to love that.
You know, we want, like, as many
cameos as we can possibly get.
Like, anybody that wants to,
like, do it that I guess
is somewhat famous.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Anyone who's -- there's so many
fans of "Good Burger."
-Yeah. So, like --
-I mean --
-I want to see what that could
be like.
Could you possibly --
-Could you?
-Come by and do --
-Because we were --
we were talking about it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Two, three, four --
♪♪
[ Audience woohoos ]
-Nice.
-Yeah.
-Of course, I would do
something-- I would do anything
with you dudes, anything.
Man, I love hanging
with you guys.
-Yes.
-I would love it, man.
I'm excited about this.
-We're very excited.
-So, but there's a script.
You guys are shooting it soon,
by the way.
-Yeah, yeah.
I think they're waiting on me
to finish upstairs.
-"Saturday Night Live,"
yeah, yeah.
Okay, so, any celebrities out
there that want to make cameos,
clear your schedule
for this summer.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Because that's when everyone's
doing it.
-Get ready.
-I also love this song,
"We're All Dudes."
-Ooh, yeah.
-Yeah, I mean, you wrote that.
-I did write it.
-How did you--
there's a fun story to this,
right?
Didn't you write it in like
a night or a day
or something like that?
-Yeah, yeah.
I wrote it at a hotel.
Brian Robins was like,
"Hey, we need a song to
the 'Welcome to Good Burger'
that you do on the show."
So, I wrote it really quickly,
and sung it for all the execs,
and they loved it.
I was, like, at the table,
and everybody was eating lunch.
And to this day,
I still get paid
from the "Good Burger" song.
-Exactly right.
That's it, see.
-But it's an uplifting song,
man.
It's real uplifting.
-It's the most positive song
there is.
-I love doing it, man.
-Yeah, we never --
We don't ever put anyone on
the spot or force anyone to do
anything...
-What's happening?
What's happening?
-...on this show.
But I'm just saying, we --
-And I see a microphone.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I see two -- Oh!
-You want us to do
a little something?
-You want to do a little song?
-You want us to do
a little something.
-Do a little song?
-Come up.
-We're doing this.
-Come on.
Put your hands together.
Get up.
♪ Oh, oh, oh ♪
♪ It's time to put our times
behind it ♪
♪ All the bad things
off your mind ♪
-♪ He's feeling good,
we're feeling good ♪
♪ We're feeling good, yeah ♪
-♪ Just hanging out,
just having fun. ♪
♪ We're number one ♪
-♪ Just hanging out,
just having fun ♪
♪ I'm a dude, he's a dude ♪
♪ She's a dude,
we're all dudes, hey ♪
♪ I'm a dude, he's a dude ♪
♪ She's a dude,
we're all dudes, hey ♪
-Kenan Thompson and
Kel Mitchell, everybody!
"Good Burger 2" will be
available to stream exclusively
on Paramount+ later this year.
Padma Lakshmi joins us
after the break. Stick around.
-♪ I'm a dude, he's a dude ♪
♪ She's a dude,
we're all dudes, hey ♪
♪ I'm a dude, he's a dude ♪
♪ She's a dude,
and we're all dudes, yeah ♪
-♪ I'm a dude, he's a dude ♪
♪ She's a dude,
we're all dudes, hey ♪
♪♪
-♪ We're all dudes, yeah ♪